- And the argument
that they make
is that Columbus came
over to the Americas
and he enslaved all the peoples,
and he raped, killed,
pillaged, and burned,
and he was a vicious
tyrant and a murderer,
and he did all of
these awful things
'cause he was a
genocidal maniac.
And the problem
with that narrative
is not just that it's unfair
or it's out of
historical context.
It's actually that
it's not true.
In the words of Carol Delaney,
who is a preeminent
Columbus historian,
the left accuses
Columbus of things
that he actually did not do,
that other Spaniards did,
that actually in many cases
Christopher Columbus tried to
stop the Spaniards from doing.
(soft dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
we're doing a special
Columbus Day edition of
"The Rubin Report" today.
I am joined by
the most notorious
Christopher Columbus apologist
on all of the internet,
a man who also wrote one
bestselling book with no words
and another best-selling
book with words
that the "New York
Times" decided
not to put on their
bestseller list.
Also, he left me
behind in crazy Cali
while he moved to the
free state of Tennessee.
Yeah, you know who it
is, Michael Knowles.
Welcome back to
"The Rubin Report."
- Great to be with you,
sir, albeit from afar.
I hope to see you in
person again soon,
if I can make it back
to that, you know,
failed state of
Newsolini's California.
- Yes, thank you for sticking me
right at the beginning
of this thing.
Now, Knowles, I asked my guys,
because it is Columbus Day,
I asked my guys who
is the foremost expert
on Christopher
Columbus, and they said,
they gave me a
long list of names.
We couldn't get any
of those people.
We got you.
- Not a single one.
- Yeah, we couldn't get them.
And then they said,
Michael Knowles,
And I said, "Well,
Chris Columbus,"
I thought, perhaps
you were the expert
on the director, Chris Columbus,
of "Home Alone" and "Harry
Potter" and "Mrs. Doubtfire."
Have you ever heard
that joke before?
- I have not heard that joke.
It's not a joke, Dave.
I would consider myself
expert on both Chrises,
both very important.
Although I suppose today we
celebrate the old Italian one.
- Yeah, okay, so let's talk
about Christopher Columbus,
'cause I actually know
that joking aside,
this is sorta close
to your heart,
the way that they've sort
of changed the very life
and the history of
Christopher Columbus.
I've watched a couple of things
that you've done on this before.
So, actually I'm not even gonna
ask you a question to start.
Why don't you just start?
Where should we start
when talking about
Christopher Columbus.
- I think we oughta quote
that great historian,
Tony Soprano.
I'll clean up the language
a little bit for your show,
'cause it's a family program.
When his son AJ is going
off about some Howard's End
revisionist woke nonsense
about Christopher Columbus,
Tony cuts him off and
says, "Hey, enough of that.
In this house, Christopher
Columbus is a hero, all right?
And that's the
end of the story."
And I think that's
absolutely true.
There are two reasons here
why we focus on Columbus Day
and why this is near
and dear to my heart.
First of all, the
identity politics,
I am an Italian-American
from New York.
Columbus Day is considered
an Italian-American holiday.
It was instituted for
the first time in 1892.
This was on the
400th anniversary
of Christopher Columbus
sailing the ocean blue.
The proximate cause of
this is that the year prior
11 Italian-Americans had
been lynched in New Orleans.
It's the largest mass
lynching in American history,
and so to make the
Italians feel nice
and welcome here in America,
there was this initial
Columbus Day celebrated,
and then later on
Franklin Roosevelt
made it an annual thing.
So the Italians, especially
those from the tri-state area,
feel very close to it.
Now, beyond the usual
sort of identity pride
that everyone seems to
be focused on these days,
why on his own merits would
Columbus get a holiday?
Well, the answer is simple.
He is the man who
discovered America.
Without Christopher Columbus,
we would not be here.
And he's a great embodiment
of Western civilization.
He is an Italian
Genoan of low birth,
who is basically
a self-made man,
and he educated himself
and he traveled all over.
He became one of the
greatest sailors of his age,
even when he was
still a young man.
He had this crazy idea
to sail to the Indies,
to find a short sea
route to the Indies.
The reasons for this
were somewhat economic,
to find a trade route, and
this is often overlooked,
they were religious,
they were spiritual.
He was a devout Catholic.
He wanted to fund another
crusade, actually.
And on his ships, he
said the book of hours,
he led the men in prayers,
he had confession and the
Eucharist before he set sail.
He was a deeply
pious religious man,
and he was intrepid,
he was fearless.
He sailed to Iceland, to
Ireland, to parts of Africa.
He makes it to the Indies,
he goes three times,
discovers a New World,
and because he so
embodies our civilization,
the left hates his guts.
- So, let's go with
that for just a moment.
So, you're basically telling me
he used the tools of
the white patriarchy
to come here and
slaughter people, right?
Isn't that where you're
going next with this?
- You know, the Italians
are a swarthy people,
getting back to our
identity politics,
so I don't how or know where
they fall in white supremacy,
but I think, yes, to the left,
he was an embodiment
of white supremacy.
And the argument that they make
is that Columbus came
over to the Americas
and he enslaved all the peoples,
and he raped, killed,
pillaged, and burned,
and he was a vicious
tyrant and a murderer,
and he did all of
these awful things
'cause he was a
genocidal maniac.
And the problem
with that narrative
is not just that it's unfair
or it's out of
historical context.
It's actually that
it's not true.
In the words of Carol Delaney,
who is a preeminent
Columbus historian,
the left accuses
Columbus of things
that he actually did not do,
that other Spaniards did,
that actually in many cases,
Christopher Columbus tried to
stop the Spaniards from doing.
When they first landed,
they met the Taino people.
Columbus told the Spaniards,
"Don't be cruel
to these people."
Now, there were other
islanders in the area,
notably the Carib islanders,
who were a little
less kind and polite
than the Taino Indians.
Columbus noticed that the Tainos
had a lot of scars on them,
on some of them, and so he
asked, "Where is that from?
It was from the Carib islanders.
The Carib islanders is where
we get the word for cannibal.
They were an island
of cannibals.
This is well-documented.
This brought the idea
of cannibalism even
into our lexicon,
our cultural lexicon.
So, not all of the
natives created equal.
Christopher Columbus befriended
one of the Indian leaders
and actually raised
his orphaned son.
So to call him racist,
bigoted, genocidal,
it is so overly simplistic,
it's so dishonest,
and frankly, it's more
fanciful and fabulous
than any of the traditional
narratives we have
that admire Columbus.
- So, since we're
taping this actually
a couple days
before Columbus Day,
I'm sure that we're in
agreement that there's no doubt
like 80,000 hit
pieces out right now.
They're doing hit pieces
post-death hit pieces
on Christopher
Columbus right now.
There's no doubt they're
saying slaughtered,
indigenous, and
all of the stuff.
Does this in some ways for you,
because you care about this,
and at the identity
politics level,
it's okay to be an Italian,
proud of Italian
heritage and history
and all of those things,
that it's like we can't defend
any of our freedoms now.
We can't even defend our current
history from 10 years ago,
that this is one
that it almost feels
like the ship has
sailed, no pun intended.
They're coming for
Christopher Columbus,
whether we like it or not.
- They are, and these hit
pieces, they crop up every year,
and they've really increased
in frequency and vitriol
since the mid 2000s.
And whenever you
look at a hit piece,
what's the first
question you gotta ask?
The first question is,
what are the sources?
Where did they get
this stuff from?
It was a little weird
that these hit pieces
all cropped up in the 2000s,
and the explanation was
that new documents revealed
that Columbus was
not a great guy,
that actually he was a
terrible genocidal maniac.
What were the documents?
You'll notice on a
lot of these articles,
you can't find, they
don't cite their sources.
It all goes back to a document
from a man named
Francisco de Bobadilla.
Francisco de Bobadilla was
Christopher Columbus' rival
for political power
in the New World.
Columbus was not just the
greatest explorer of his age,
but he also was the
governor of the Indies.
He was a less competent governor
than he was an explorer,
and actually a lot of
the harsher treatment
of the Native Americans
was as a result
of Christopher Columbus
being outfoxed politically
by much less scrupulous men.
And so one of the people who
stabbed Columbus in the back
was this guy de Bobadilla.
I'm not saying Christopher
Columbus was perfect.
Obviously, he wasn't,
he was a human.
No human is perfect, not in
this day and age, at least.
I can really only name one
person, one, maybe two.
I don't know, Dave, you're a
nice guy, but I don't think so.
- Thank you, thank you.
When we look at this
historical record,
I think the comparison
here would be
if you were looking at a
history of Hillary Clinton
and you said, okay, well,
what's a fair history
of Hillary Clinton?
How about this one
written by Donald Trump?
I'm gonna use this as my
sole evidence that Hillary,
or vice versa, you know,
the history of Donald Trump
written by Hillary Clinton.
Regardless of the
facts on the ground,
and we can talk about
all of the complex facets
of Columbus' life, it's
simply preposterous
to take his chief
political rival
as the gospel truth on the man,
especially when that
narrative is so contradicted
by many other
esteemed historians
and people who were
there at the time.
I think of Bartolome
de Las Casas,
the first resident
bishop of the Americas.
Bartolome de Las Casas was
honest about Columbus' faults,
and he said the man
didn't govern perfectly,
but he's considered one
of the greatest defenders
of the Native Americans,
and yet de Las Casas
remained a lifelong admirer
of Christopher Columbus.
And I think we need
to take into account
that historical
perspective as well
before we throw the guy
over the ship as it were.
- All right, so
with that in mind,
let's spend our remaining time
talking about the good stuff.
We know the
controversies are coming.
We know what they're gonna say.
Okay, so be it.
And by the way, none of these
people are leaving America.
None of these people
are doing anything
other than complaining
and everything else.
But let's be productive here
and get some real knowledge.
Just on the exploration
part itself,
are there any
interesting stories
that sort of got him to decide,
"Yeah, I'm gonna get in a
boat and see what happens?"
It's a pretty crazy thing.
I mean, the only comparable
thing we have in modern times
is that Elon Musk is trying
to send people to Mars
or that kinda thing.
- Yes, the thing
you need to know
about Christopher
Columbus' exploration
is that the man was unique.
This is not something
to be looked at
as the mere tides of history
and someone was going to
discover the Americas,
and, oh, you know,
if it wasn't Chris,
it would have been
somebody else.
No, Christopher Columbus
was so ruthlessly determined
and ambitious to
find the sea route
that he, first of
all, educated himself.
He educated himself, became
literate, became a Spaniard.
He was an Italian guy,
but he became a Spaniard,
'cause he thought
that was going to be
basically his best
chance to go on over.
He lobbied the king of Portugal.
The king of Portugal refused.
He then goes and lobbies
the king and queen of Spain.
They refused as well,
but through basically sheer
tyranny of will and personality,
he finally gets
Isabella, Queen Isabella,
to relent and fund this voyage.
He had already had a lot of
experience at sea before that.
And then he sets to sea.
What does he have,
all these wonderful
tools at his disposal?
No, he's got a
compass and the stars.
He used dead reckoning
to make it across.
So, you'll often hear
people today say,
"Christopher Columbus,
he didn't even end up
where he wanted to end up.
He wanted to end up
in the East Indies.
And what, he found Bermuda,"
or whatever, not Bermuda.
He found The Bahamas,
he found the Caribbean.
And you think,
well, I don't know,
the guy had a compass
and he had the stars.
How far would you make it?
Probably not very far.
He also had to
put down a mutiny.
- I can't get to the 405
without my GPS, so I got you.
- I know, of course
not, none of us can.
On this voyage, as they were
going a far greater distance
I think than many people
were prepared to undertake,
Christopher Columbus had
to put down a mutiny.
So, here you do see a little
bit of his leadership skill.
Maybe he wasn't the greatest
governor of the Indies,
but he did keep
these men in line,
and they finally do spot land.
And he I think owes a lot
of it to his faith in God.
When he finally does
land in the Caribbean,
the first island he lands at,
he calls it San Salvador,
right, the Savior.
He deals with all of these
difficult political problems.
He is brought back
to Spain in chains,
so he undergoes a
lot of persecution.
And Columbus doesn't just
complain about this, by the way.
He thinks he was
unjustly persecuted.
I think he was largely
There were some
cynical motives for it,
which is that as long
as Christopher Columbus
was a criminal,
then the crown didn't need to
pay him what they owed him.
So, there were a lot of
political machinations
going on in Spain.
But he understood that
perhaps he was suffering
because of his own failings,
And he writes about
this in his journals.
So, he actually does
look in on himself.
And the two-dimensional
picture is just so silly,
not to harp too much on
the criticisms of him,
but I think there
is an important one
that we need to focus on
here, which is ourselves.
In the spirit of Columbus
looking in on his own failings,
we need to look in on ourselves.
Without Christopher Columbus,
we would not be here.
the Hispanic people
would not exist.
There would be no such thing
as Latinos or Hispanics, right,
which is Latino people
come from the mixture
of the American
indigenous peoples
and the Spaniards who come over.
So, if you are an
Hispanic person,
you owe your very
ethnic identity to
Christopher Columbus.
And we, of course, owe our
existence here in the New World.
And so I think before
we cast stones,
we should recognize
that we are standing
on the shoulders of giants,
this giant in particular,
and yet we think
that we're flying.
- What else don't we know
about those first days
when he reaches the New World?
Is there anything
particularly interesting?
It's just like hard to...
Well, how long did it take
by the way to get across?
- I forget the exact
number of days.
I used to know this pretty well,
but I forget the exact timing.
There are some
interesting stories though
when he lands the first time,
and I think this is
also really important
when we're talking about
the Native Americans,
the indigenous peoples
from the region,
'cause I don't mean to downplay
the suffering that they endured.
Many of them did endure
a lot of suffering.
But the Native Americans
that he encountered,
I mentioned this a
little bit earlier,
were all sorts of
different people,
and some of them were good
and some of them
were not so good.
And some of the groups of
native Caribbeans were good
and some of them
were not so good.
And the thing we find about them
when we read Columbus' writings,
when we read the
writings of other people
who were on the voyage,
is that those indigenous
peoples were a lot like us.
That is, they were people
and they had some
good characteristics
bad characteristics,
and the way that these
peoples developed over time.
When you're talking
about that interaction
of Columbus with
the natives there,
you're talking about the first
modern colonial interactions
in the modern era.
And so if there were
going to be problems,
if there were going
to be failures,
to be mistakes made,
recognize you're
talking about something
that is so historic,
that Columbus is
credited in many ways
with giving birth
to this modern era
that we're all living in.
- Would you like
to see the modern
American-Italian
community stand up more
for Columbus' legacy?
I mean, that episode
of "The Sopranos,"
I know the one
you're talking about,
it's the very famous
Columbus Day episode
when they're trying
to tear down,
some activists are trying
to tear down a statue
somewhere in Jersey.
I wonder, should the
Italian community
be getting more up
in arms over this?
- I do think that the Italians
have a special role here
in defending Columbus.
I don't love identity politics,
and it's not like I wake up
every morning and I think,
"Gosh, I am proudest of the fact
that my skin is a little
swarthy and I eat cannoli,"
and things like that.
But the Italians have
a special role here.
If they're not going to
defend Columbus, who will?
And the Italians
ought to be happy
about their
influence on America.
First of all, America is
named after an Italian,
Amerigo Vespucci, the mapmaker.
You've got the Verrazano Bridge.
You've got Christopher
Columbus, obviously,
so many places named after him.
And I think this raises
another question.
Why are towns, universities,
state, countries,
whole countries, named
after Christopher Columbus?
Why did people once admire him
and they don't
admire him anymore?
I suppose part of that might be
because unscrupulous journalists
are relying on ridiculous
historical records,
but I suspect it has to
do more with ourselves.
We don't like ourselves so
much anymore as a civilization,
and Columbus, because
he played such a role
in developing that
civilization and embodying it,
I think he bears a lot of the
brunt of this sort of thing.
You asked for
interesting episodes
from those first
encounters he had,
well, most of what we see
from those earliest encounters
between Columbus and the natives
are him imploring people
to treat them well,
please, Spaniards, do
not deceive the natives,
do not deceive them in trade,
do not be too harsh on them.
And that side of the man,
you never really get to see.
Later on, more
difficult circumstances
developed, of course.
No one is denying that.
It reminds me of
Chesterton's fence.
G.K. Chesterton, the English
writer, has this famous idea
that there are two kinds
of reformers, right?
The reformer who goes
up and sees a fence
in the middle of nowhere,
just a white fence,
it doesn't seem to
serve any purpose,
and who says, "Tear
down that fence.
I have no idea why that fence
was erected in the first place."
And then there's another
type of reformer who says,
"Hold on a second,
if you do not know the
purpose of that fence,
if you don't know why that was
erected in the first place,
then don't touch it.
Go figure out why it was
erected in the first place
and then tear it down.
And I think that's what
we should begin with here,
is a little bit of
humility to say,
"Why was this man admired
for so very long?"
Well, maybe shockingly,
it's us here in 2021
who are missing something,
and it's not just the
diluted old, awful people
who came before us that
we've gotta tear down.
- Knowles, that kinda feels
like the right ending.
(Michael laughing)
I think you did it, you
brought the old into the new,
you brought the Old
World to the New World.
We bridged the sea.
- (laughing) We've done
it, we've reached the sea.
I hope we can defend the
great Christopher Columbus.
I hope people don't
tear down his statues
too much into the near future,
because the thing is,
when you tear down
your entire country,
when you tear down your
entire civilization,
one, some of those
statutes might clobber you
and clobber the
things that you love,
but you're going to end
up living amid ruins.
And all cultures,
all civilizations,
are gonna have to
admire certain people.
We're gonna have to
admire certain values.
I wanna live in a civilization
that admires the great
men who came before us,
who gave us our culture,
that admires the intrepid,
determined, faithful,
intelligent, ambitious
sort of episodes
that I think are
really well typified
and really well exemplified
by Christopher Columbus,
or we're gonna admire
a lot of the bad guys
who are running around running
roughshod over our culture.
Make your choice.
Everybody's gotta
serve somebody.
- In many ways, that's exactly
what the whole damn thing
is about right now,
and Knowles, you are
the living embodiment
of Christopher Columbus
because you left Los
Angeles for the unchartered,
the unknown county,
country of Tennessee.
It's a country, right?
- This is true,
and just like
Christopher Columbus,
I've had wonderful
encounters with the natives
here in Tennessee as well.
(both men laughing)
- Knowles, thanks
for doing this.
Have a happy Columbus Day,
and I'll see you
in Tennessee soon,
and then we'll see if
they'll let you back in LA,
I have no idea.
- Ciao.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.